il y à 8 8 millions de personnes pauvres
en france en 2018
c'est à dire 8 8 millions de français
gagnant moins de 1000 26 euros par mois
c'est 1 million de plus qu'il ya dix ans
date de la dernière crise économique
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale le
taux de pauvreté diminue et doucement
mais sûrement en france mais au milieu
des années 2000
il y à une stagnation voire une légère
hausse
première alerte en 2007 le repli se
confirme sur les marchés boursiers les
principales places européennes ont
clôturé en baisse ce soir alors que les
banques américaines n'ont pas encore
fait faillite
les français ont des craintes pour leur
avenir chômage pauvreté
plus que jamais les parents craignent
pour l'avenir de leurs enfants selon un
sondage ipsos pour le secours populaire
80 % des français estiment que les
générations futures auront plus de
risques de se retrouver un jour en
situation de précarité 2008 les banques
américaines en faillite
mais c'est en 2011 que la crise atteint
son pic en france avec une augmentation
du taux de pauvreté 14 7 % des français
sont considérés comme pauvres cette
année là ça représente exactement 8
millions neuf cent soixante seize mille
personnes un jeune sur cinq vit
aujourd'hui en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
une génération qui se précarisent touché
de plein fouet par la crise économique
ils sont étudiants salariés aux chômeurs
les 18 25 ans doute en leur avenir et
n'ont plus confiance dans la société
mais depuis 2013 le taux de pauvreté en
france stagne il reste bloqué autour des
14 % malgré le retour de la croissance
économique
un taux qui reste tout de même un des
plus bas d'europe
par exemple
16 5 % des allemands sont considérés
comme pauvres et 22 3% les espagnols
[Musique]